okay all right okay well thank you so
much it was nice to talk to you yeah all
right back to you guys
Hugh Grant may not have been nominated
for an Oscar at the 95th Academy Awards
on Sunday but he definitely took home
the award for the most awkward red
carpet interview it's pretty intense it
all went down before the Big Show when
the actor stopped to chat with Ashley
Graham during ABC's countdown to Oscars
95. the interview started off with Hugh
keeping his answers brief what are you
most excited to see tonight to see yeah
well I know that you probably watched a
few of the movies are you excited to see
anybody win do you have your hopes up
for anyone
um
not not no one in particular okay well
what are you wearing tonight then just
my suit your suit who made your you
didn't
um I can't remember my tailor that's
okay
to the tailor some viewers were quick to
slam you online calling him rude one van
pointed out that he should stay home if
he's too good for his industry of choice
but it was the eye roll at the end that
really had people worked up okay all
right okay well thank you so much it was
nice to talk to you yeah all right back
to you guys rewind
zoom in now play back yeah
yep that's an eye roll all right Hugh
showed up for Hollywood's biggest night
to present alongside His Four Weddings
and a funeral co-star Andy McDowell
lovely to be here it is lovely uh we're
actually here to do two things the first
is to raise awareness about the vital
importance of using a good moisturizer
Andy's been wearing one every day for
the last 29 years I've never used one in
my life and while that mini reunion made
headlines so did Hugh's cameo in Glass
Onion last year
yeah
uh
can I help you fans are totally freaking
out with Hugh grants yeah Cameo and also
just that romance there between Daniel
Craig and Hugh Grant can we see more of
it we'll see I mean look I should only
be so lucky to have Hugh Grant and more
mystery movies and so we'll see what
happens Blanc
there's someone here for you
with a box so we might see more that's
amazing everything's a movie
um so tell me what does it feel like to
be in Glass Onion it was such an amazing
film I really loved it I love a thriller
how fun is it to shoot something like
that well I'm barely in it I'm in it for
about three seconds yeah but still bill
you showed up and you had fun right uh
almost we gotta hand it to Ashley she
kept calm and carried on
okay all right okay well thank you so
much it was nice to talk to you yeah all
right back to you guys
[Music]